In this problem, a manufacturer
generates a liquid waste that contains
6% by weight of tuine as its principal
hazardous organic component. The waste
has a specific gravity of 0.95.
During incineration, 3,000 gall of the
waste are burned in a single batch. If
the combustion efficiency is 99.95%,
what is the maximum allowable release of
tuine in kilograms from the batch?
So in this problem, one of the key words
we might want to look at if we don't
know where to start would be
incineration.
If we search this in the reference
manual, this will take us to a section
titled incineration under air.
in there is a section that we already
used in a previous problem on
destruction and removal efficiency. So
the equation for that is going to be
destruction and removal efficiency
equals W in minus W out
over
W in
times 100%.
W in is the mass feed rate of any
particular principal organic hazardous
constituent and mass out is the emission
rate coming back out of the incineration
process. So the first thing we have to
do in this problem is find the weight.
So, in order to find the weight leaving
the incineration that is legally
allowable, we first have to find the
total weight going into the
incineration.
So, we know that 3,000 gallons are
burned and it is a 6% by weight of the
component. And we also can see that this
waste has a specific gravity of 0.95.
So step one is find the weight of tuine
or any hazardous organic component the
problem might throw at you.
So, we have 3,000 gallons
time 8.34
pound
per gallon*
1 kilogram
over 2.2 2 lb
times the specific gravity of 0.95.
A note about specific gravity.
This provides the mass in kilogram per
cubic meter of waste.
And this is why we are including it in
the equation here. And finally we have
the 6%.
[Music]
So our units will cross out to kilograms
here. And if we solve this we should get
just about 648.24
kg.
So now that we have the mass of the
ingoing contaminant into the
incinerator,
we can use the required combustion
efficiency to find the maximum allowable
release
from the process.
So our required combustion efficiency is
99.95%.
And that's going to be equal to our WN
of 648.24 24 kg
minus
W out which is our unknown over
648.24
again
all times 100%.
So, if we'd like, we can simplify this
problem by dividing by 100 to get rid of
the percents and simplifying this to
0.9995*
648.24
kg
equals
648.24
24 kg minus W out.
Simplifying this we can get W out equals
0.32
kg which is our second answer over here.
So in this problem we actually do need
every number that is provided. Um, there
could be cases where you might have
believed you didn't need the specific
gravity, in which case you might have
ended up with one of these other answers
here. Um, but that's important to the
problem since it helps us convert our
mass to a volume or the other way
around. But if you can keep that in
mind, that's maybe the only thing that
comes close to being a trick in this
type of problem. And that's it.
[Music]